a green-headed girl
she seems so real
greetings we are the magician morticians
the artist of the afterlife
so as your Masters we order you to turn
around and uh
hello everyone first of all thank you
for bringing me back to my terrified
child watching like secret of the nymph
and like all of those secret of the new
I love that my generation terrified
children Henry Jordan key lyric I love
that y'all are bringing that back but
Henry I have to talk to you starting
this because I really do love that
shortly after these gentlemen ruined my
name Jacqueline yeah
thank you but shortly after you watching
them do that you also like got the
inspiration for this incredible tale
that became Lindell and wow so I really
want to go back to you watching first of
all just you watching key and peel
episodes like that I just want to be
there so can you bring us back there
it's just you know you're looking you
hear things and you look at it and then
you know they can't stay this good
because they can't they can't I can't I
can't wait for them to fail
and they never did they always
entertained and enlightened and just
just their their range is phenomenal
and um
you know my my one of The Producers Alan
Golds with vane and who was also a
manager
she kept pushing me you know that old
story that went to a while it just just
at a certain point it may have been
finally the Terry's episode
I'm just going you know
give you
yo went a little wild and it's just sort
of like wow that'd be amazing if I could
get them but I mean I I think one of the
most
they were so surprising they could play
anybody
you know any ethnicity any social class
any gender
and um
they were so good at like pulling the
faint you know like you think you're
going here yeah I know how this is going
to go no and they always
had you know incredible surprise so you
know I I think the I know the best
comedy to do over the best sketch artist
ever
um they're maybe they're both that's too
much
[Music]
put the brakes
what's so interesting is I do love this
because I'm not saying that every single
sketch comedy duo they got an email from
Henry or any of his people would have
not been delighted by that but I really
do feel with this duo in particular and
y'all's love for animation and I know
you're as particular level of
stop-motion animation this was literally
probably like I don't know like getting
like a comedy great coming in your DMs
like this is like so what was that
moment like for both of you because
again I know the monkey paw logo yeah
yeah right right you know I'm this is my
grandmother so which that didn't exist
back when he reached out so it was kind
of like me you know I went and met him
first
we went to some
hotel that
Boutique Hotel in Burbank and I was
basically my secret that I was like a
huge fan
and I didn't know I thought my my
presumption by the way was that you know
what happens would be sort of
in Ash to be uh sort of comic release
sort of side character to an animated
thing so anyway I was already going to
say yes and I was first of all when he
told me you know this was something he
wanted for us like this was something he
had us in mind for as essentially the
leads and he told us the story and he
told us a bit about cat and heli as well
and I just you know I I fell in love
with it I fell in love with the the fact
that just like you said we were at this
place in both of our careers before
before get out happened before Keegan
Keegan went off and made all his uh
films
all the things so it really was at a
point where it was like we were we're in
awe of this person who at the very least
felt like he needed us at the time and
that was just that was yeah no that was
that's a good characterization of that
Synergy because it was the same thing
for me I
I was I I think when I first saw it it
was one of those things where this
happened a couple times in my career
right now
they can't
maybe that Henry sucks right but the
brain goes into
what can't be any other well what other
Henry sucks would it be but your brain
is going this is this is too good this
is too much and and and I knew
I knew that they shared a sensibility
like I like the Macabre and I like
things that are unexpected and I'm an
enormous select fan but I I was like
this seems like this could fit us like a
glove yeah because whatever our Synergy
together was going to work with his and
I I just it was one of those no-brainer
situations yeah oh I really do love this
too because as happy as I was for that
you guys have already shown like with
just your comedic timing and your
comedic sensibilities and so I really
love the idea of you guys getting to
play in this world because it is dark
and it really does go to these really
incredible places and it does so from
the very first scene and lyric I have to
say like I don't know how the script
came to you or how you first read that
but I like when you read it was this the
what you see now in this character was
it there from the beginning because I do
have to say like that first five minutes
I'm already like oh I know what this is
let's get in and like let's get let's
get scared a little bit I really did
love that was that the initial thing for
you or how did you come into it uh yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
um how was really going to turn now or
how I was going to play it out I was
just like okay
follow directions and see what happens
but
um
yeah what the part I got
um when I auditioned for it
I think she was going into the Catholic
girls school for the first time and it
was it was a it was a little scene it
really didn't have
much that was talking about her story
you know so I'm I'm like
okay
um
so I just I just I don't really know
what I did but um well I'm listening to
you and I can already hear it
it's like you can hear it in your voice
like I'm literally what's crazy about
this movie for folks who haven't seen it
yet is it's an adventure it's an artist
has more similar to like tuso in
Underground Railroad and Odysseus and
like this real journey that she goes on
which I love and for Henry with you I
know that the journey that you sort of
put this character on in this journey
it's nothing new for you we've seen you
do a young girl's tale as she goes
through these perilous Ventures
um but with this one I do feel like you
you in particular said that there was a
shift in how you wanted to tell the
stories particularly knowing the
characters that you were gonna involve
and just how much of the production
shifted when Key and Peele came on board
so can you talk about that and just how
you really sort of developed the story
of Adventure and how it shifted as the
characters came in
um key and peel were the only only ones
I was never going to go out to it took a
while to find lyric and there was a lot
of just inauthentic young actors um
talented in the in their in their ways
but um she was the first person after
listening to dozens and dozens maybe a
hundred I had this authenticity that I
just felt
um this is gonna work and I think you
had just started on this is us
Landing lyric really
contributes so much to like me figuring
out who who that protagonist is and how
she thinks
um you know I think we did kind of a
mind milled
and she you know right right away kind
of helped guide me as that character
was um that script back then you know
four years ago three years ago
it's real different it evolved it
changed a lot
um
you know what's the tone I think these
these demons were more demonic
um the mean girls were more cliche mean
girls but it was more interesting to
like
turn cliches on their heads yeah yeah
and um
so I'd say it's just the main journey is
that every you have to love every
character in your film
and
support them and find out well what's
the best
version and then of course you know with
what these these two guys bring in their
improv skills got to be wide open
um
and and welcome it I remember I think I
I had like one mild interact you know a
we had a rough moment and then I I just
I backed out and said well it is funny
you're right
why it's why I came to you so why would
I reject it I did only once I I will say
I do have to brought that out because
improv people have met this and maybe
it's just I've been around too many
comedians there's an immediacy to improv
and y'all are some impatient people
because of it like there's an immediacy
joke laugh there's just so
animation is not that Medium it is very
much like we're gonna plan a c for a
joke that you're gonna hear in six years
yeah I wrote about Wendell and Wild on
one of my very first pieces for Rotten
Tomatoes back in March of 2019 you can
look up that by line so I'm very happy
that you guys need to talk about it now
but for you like what is that like
because you've done a ton of Animation
work at this point but I do think that
that's got to be a hard thing like in
general for anybody that does improv
yeah it is it isn't I mean as an
Enterprise that immediacy you're saying
is part of it it's almost in the DNA of
improvisation is that it's almost that
it it attracts it can attract impatient
people to it or um but I think part of
it is he I still cannot understand the
alchemy that allows him to spawn for him
to simultaneously be able to say I know
I have to animate it painstakingly this
way and yet I'm still gonna open this up
to see what Avenue they're going to go
down and if indeed it is a better or
enhances the story it wasn't for me
for having produced other things I try
to I try to at some place in my brain
keep an eye on the full story so there's
sometimes but then I
to no avail there's still times when
we're in the booth and we just start
grooving and then there might be a
little voice that goes
and there's another little voice that
goes but we're having such a great time
hey we like those DVDs though those DVD
of Netflix
um listen to me sorry special features
[Laughter]
please guys
Jordan I want to bring it back to
YouTube because I do love that uh Henry
I did a chat with him off of the trailer
release of this one and he talked about
when you guys first try talking again
this was before get out this is before
any of that I remember him saying he
said that he told the story about yeah
I'm gonna go shoot this little horror
movie of mine and you said it like very
humbly and then it was uh Henry said
after that I the movie got a better
chance to be made but it also meant that
Jordan was busy for like ever so it took
a long time to sort of like put the
wheels in motion but talk about you when
you did put the wheels of motion it was
under the monkey par Banner this was a
huge part of what you set forth not just
with you as a ironist but as a producer
and a production company it's kind of in
the DNA before I even get out in a lot
of ways right I mean the the plan for
monkey paw and and this sort of genre or
sub-genre of film that we were we're
kind of privileged to be a part of the
plan for that was set you know before
get out even came out and so this was a
project that you know I I think I had
the the dream that it could happen but
it it's it's true that you know
sometimes it takes time and a certain
amount of things to come together and
the timing worked and then that's when
you you just take advantage of that
timing and so yeah it's just one of the
the wonderful things you know having to
leave and go uh make my my films yeah
I'll only be gone a few weeks
it's uh
I know it's so afraid but it's it's one
of them but you know I have to say just
the this thing that we're talking about
the the combination between
meticulousness planning and the openness
it's it's something in each one of my
films I'm continuously evolving and
inspired by Henry by by through his
process so funny because it is a project
I know it's it's that's well said
Jacqueline because it's free get out but
it's completely on brand yeah it shows
that it shows that there's a there is a
a healthy myopicness about what about
your about about what you're making it's
so on brand this is awesome yeah and we
got to get out of here because lyric is
a busy woman
but before she does get back on that set
can you give me anything
dang Marvel is good
no they're yeah
I appreciate it but we're gonna be
looking out we're gonna be looking out
right